We Begin the day unable to say that the
threat of war in eastern Ukraine has
passed earlier today Russia announced
that it was pulling back some of its
forces near the Ukrainian border and
sending them back to their Barracks at
first it seemed to be a tentative sign
of de-escalation coming exactly when U.S
and European intelligence have been
warning that Russia is now ready to
launch a military strike on Ukraine
let's pull in the map here it tells a
story of anything but de-escalation over
the past few months the Russian military
has positioned more than a hundred
thousand troops you see right there
along the eastern and the southern
border with Ukraine Ukraine's northern
border with Belarus you see right there
it has has now about 30 000 Russian
troops in position the Pentagon says
eastern Ukraine is almost surrounded and
is the obvious Target for an
overwhelming military very Invasion the
head of NATO today warned that shuffling
around troops while leaving weapons in
place is not a sign of de-escalation
there are signs from Moscow that
diplomacy should continue
this gives grounds for cautious optimism
but so far we have not seen any sign of
de-escalation on the ground Russia has
amassed a fighting force in and around
Ukraine
unprecedented since the Cold War
everything is now in place for a new
attack
but Russia still has time to step back
from the brink
stop preparing for war
and start working for a peaceful
solution
my first guest tonight says there is a
solution to this crisis and it involves
a moratorium on NATO expansion Thomas
Graham was senior director for Russia on
the National Security Council as and
Special Assistant to former President
George W bush he is now with the Council
on Foreign Relations Mr Graham it's good
to have you on the program good to be
here you write that a moratorium on
NATO's Eastward expansion for 20 to 25
years could be the answer to ending the
impasse that we are in right now why is
it that idea gaining any traction
well I think it has become uh part of
the public debate uh certainly in Europe
but to some extent in the United States
and even in Russia uh you know I note
that the German reporter asked the
question at the press conference between
the chancellor and President Putin today
as to whether a moratorium was a
possibility now neither man answered the
question but I think that's evidence
that it is part of the public debate
today the German Chancellor said that
Ukraine's membership in NATO is not on
the agenda and he said it will not be on
the agenda while he and Vladimir Putin
are in office now Schultz is speaking to
what many diplomats say that former
Soviet republics including Ukraine are
still years away from being ready for
NATO membership am I reading that right
absolutely and I think that almost any
NATO official in any U.S official would
say the same thing we're not talking
about any near-term membership by any
countries of the former Soviet States
and so I think that really is off the
table for an extended period And I do
believe that some agreement on that and
how long that period is is going to be
part of the final solution The
Diplomatic question is how you're going
to formulate that to the satisfaction of
Moscow Brussels and Washington
and all of this is assuming that NATO
will exist in its current form in 20 to
50 years from now I mean that assumption
though it comes with some pitfalls
doesn't it
well certainly nobody knows what the
future is going to be like and that's
one of the reasons why an agreement on a
moratorium might eventually find
approval from Moscow who knows what's
going to happen in 2025 years but I do
think that we will see significant
transformation in NATO under any
circumstances the world has changed uh
the interest of European allies has
changed the United States has to focus
on East Asia as well so we will see
transformation in the way a NATO NATO
functions uh if indeed uh NATO continues
to exist over the very long term
let's talk about the past for just a
moment 15 years ago at the Munich
security conference Vladimir Putin
lashed out at the U.S and Native for
expanding Eastward take a listen to a
clip of what he said
one state and of course first and
foremost the United States has
overstepped its National borders in
every way
this is visible in the economic
political cultural and humanitarian
policies it imposes on other nations
well who would like that who could be
happy about it
come with the batteries
Mr Graham what was the thinking inside
the White House and at the National
Security Council at the time it was
Vladimir Putin was he not taken
seriously
well you know I think that in the the
White House at that time uh they
understood that that Russia and
President Putin himself personally were
dissatisfied with NATO expansion uh but
NATO had already gone through two rounds
by the late 1990s and in
2004 uh and the the sense was that like
it or uh or not that Russia really was
too weak to prevent the United States
and NATO for moving forward if that's
what they decided to do and that would
be offered that will be able at the end
of the day to offer enough concessions
or or symbiotic steps to Putin so that
he would accept NATO's extension
expansion Eastward now if we bring it
back to the present let me get your read
on this how close do you think we are
right now to seeing a military invasion
of eastern Ukraine
I don't think that we're close at all I
think it's clear that Russia has put in
place the forces that it needs for
military uh Invasion but every American
official a NATO official says that the
the political decision has been made I
don't see a political decision being
made in the near future to do that the
risks are tremendous uh Putin I think is
engaged in a war of nerds at this point
we will wrap it up ratchet up detention
ratchet it down in the hopes that that
will lead to some concessions on the
western side and on the part of Ukraine
Putin has said that the Russian Duma has
backed a resolution to recognize the
rebel controlled areas of eastern
Ukraine as independent do you think that
that is going to happen I mean wouldn't
that throw a wrench in all of this
diplomacy
no not at all I think again this is part
of the war of nerves at this point uh
putting another sort of Tool uh in uh
into Putin's pocket that he can use to
put pressure on Ukraine but if he were
to recognize the independence of these
separatist republics then in fact he
sacrificed one of the things that he
wants over the long term and that is
autonomous regions inside Ukraine that
are loyal to Russia that he can use to
impact on both the domestic politics and
the foreign policy of an independent
Ukraine
Thomas Graham with the Council on
Foreign Relations Mr Graham we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight valuable context in this crisis
thank you
thank you
well after Emmanuel macron and Boris
Johnson the latest European leader to
visit Moscow was German Chancellor Olaf
Schultz today and if his host opts for
an invasion of Ukraine he could be the
last to visit for quite some time for
the foreseeable future Schultz shares
the same goal as his French and British
counterparts to stop a war in Europe he
came to Moscow with a warning that any
attack on Ukraine would result in
immediate and hard-hitting sanctions was
President Vladimir Putin was he
listening
The Diplomatic options are far from
exhausted the task now must be to work
resolutely and courageously towards a
peaceful resolution of this crisis we
view the deterrence of Russia by force
as a direct and immediate threat to our
national security which the legal
agreements based on our drafts are
designed to remove
first Germans and for all Europeans it
is clear that lasting security cannot be
achieved against Russia only with Russia
we all agree on this in NATO and in the
European Union so it should be possible
to find a solution
I repeat the answers to our proposed
security guarantees given to us by the
United States and NATO do not address
the fundamental Russian demands
or earlier this month the Kremlin shut
down the Russian operations of this
channel deutschevelop our Moscow Bureau
was closed and our journalist
accreditations revoked it was seen as
retaliation for German media Regulators
Banning the German language programming
of the Russian state-backed broadcaster
known as RT despite the ban our chief
political editor Michaela kufner she
traveled with the German Chancellor to
Moscow today during the joint press
conference between Putin and Schultz
mckella posed the first question
the question that all Europeans are
asking is whether despite the close ties
with Russia there will be another war in
Europe can you in this moment rule out
the possibility of War yes
will you rule out a war in Europe
do we want war
even though of course we don't that is
exactly why we put forward proposals to
open negotiations
the first question there from dwu we are
certain that President Putin got the
message DW continues to hope that it's
Moscow Bureau will be allowed to reopen
sooner rather than later
well earlier we spoke with our chief
political editor Michaela kufner she is
traveling with Chancellor Schultz
well it appears that there wasn't
necessarily a deep discussion about it
but it certainly is a sign and it would
make it much more difficult to now go
into a full offensive at just 24 hours
later would be mixed signals also to a
Russian public because let's not forget
that Vladimir Putin is speaking to
Russians when he is in an international
press conference like that we also heard
talk from the defense Ministry that some
of the objectives of those Maneuvers as
it was called
um were met so that would allow for that
step at the same time a Stern warning
from Vladimir Putin who said he didn't
want war either that he yes he would
still engage in further talks at the
same time he would not allow it to
happen that things get changed which are
done difficult to alter for the Russian
side so he won't see those dragged out
as he put it so a bit of time brought
through diplomacy for now was still very
uncertain map ahead
that was Michaela cookner there in
Moscow